[Music]
in guilty conscious news oh that's me
after a hamburger I thought you're a
[ __ ]
no not [ __ ] hamburgers and don't hand
up cakes and donuts I feel guilty about
food anymore so good really have sex
with my friends chicken sandwich and
then watch them eat it that is that is
was that you a minute yeah I'm happy to
put a face on that now it was a black
guy submitted by Cory loves JK hey Cory
thanks Cory hi Kai the former waitress
returns one thousand dollars she stole
from a restaurant in the 90s Oh
someone's at a 12-step program yeah sure
oh yeah this former waitress from
Arizona she stole it in the 90s isn't it
worth like 5,000 for inflation damn
y'all business yeah I was like I'd even
think of that I was like holy [ __ ] it's
probably a couple more now yep cuz I
remember my mom buying a house in like
the 90s and it was like a hundred and
eighty thousand and if they can LA
there's no way you could buy a house for
a hundred eighty thousand now you ever
been by LAX those little shacks those
are probably minimum half a mil yeah
it's not even more and their shacks yeah
you hear an airplane all day I think she
did account for inflation because she
says she stole a couple hundred but she
gave a thousand oh that's inflation and
[ __ ] interest yeah and I'm sorry
attached to [ __ ] that's given me some
flashbacks of things I should do so this
is the letter that the restaurant
received I will read it to you I was
down and out and I needed some crack it
says dear core a lot of family I worked
for you as a waitress very briefly back
in the 1990's while a student at
University of Arizona one of the waiters
I worked with had encouraged me to
forget to bring in a few drinks a shift
and pocket the cash and for some stupid
reason I did it I grew up in the church
I knew better I hadn't stolen a dime
before
nor have I since thankfully I was a
terrible waitress and you've all fired
me before it could amount to more than a
few hundred dollars total it's been 20
years but I still carry great remorse
I'm very sorry that I stole from you
please accept my apology and this money
as a routine mint and 20 years of
interest may God forever bless you and
your family what if what if they sold
the restaurant it's not even the same
people anymore yeah it is okay I think
you never ever felt guilty for something
I did that far in the past Oh life is
all about guilts for me man I want to
talk about it there's there's a there's
a several homes that I broke into but
one in particular I feel [ __ ]
horrible for is it was a senior couple
and their daughter a kid that lived in
there too so they're all old but then I
grabbed one of the drawers I pulled it
and I saw a birthday card in in the
birthday card
there was a [ __ ] ton of cash like two
three hundred dollars I took that [ __ ]
and I we got a bunch of other things but
then I mean they might be all old and
dead now but because they were seniors
at the time but I that that's just burnt
in my memory like [ __ ] I took somebody's
happy birthday oh that is cash I read
the card
I read the card another thing that I
always used to do is just run in and the
first thing I would do is just put all
the pictures down cuz I didn't want
people looking at me with the
consciousness yeah [ __ ] funny dude it
takes it pissy and flush the toilet I
specifically remember what we did right
after that we went and filled up art
cars tank with gas and then after that
we went and got some Chinese food and
during that whole time
I was eating food I felt like every bite
of rice was like sadness it was good but
it was like ah that was some [ __ ] like I
hit an all-new low and then the rest of
the money I think my friends just burned
it on [ __ ] crack and I don't even
remember Lee correct yeah they would
most of it was just for crack yeah
you're stealing birthday money you're
you're smoking crack
but see I know you're a couple you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I don't know I
don't feel bad I've never done something
like I don't even remember where I know
the vision I know the area that we hit
because we hit three homes in that area
but that one was the one that's just
burnt in my soul I know the street and
then I keep feeling like I want to knock
on that door and give them some money
and tell them I'm sorry I keep having
that feeling these family now I don't
even remember where the house is and
there's so many that we did but that was
the one that made me feel like [ __ ] dude
I hit an all-time low one time I was at
a taco shop in Vegas and people just
left this wallet on the video game and
he had $300 cash on it and I just
grabbed it and jumped in my car and I
saw them run frantically in and I was
like man imma keep they probably need
this cash but I kept it I do I do I even
in that moment I knew like I was I was
asking those people and and I felt bad
but you're like I need this cash like I
do big shows at the Comedy Store and I'd
pay people like good money to do it
because I'm blessed these guys do it and
I gave Eddie Bravo a you know some cash
in a couple hundred bucks yeah
and he just hit me up he's like hey dude
I lost my envelope do you think anybody
uh might've turned it I go dude it's
hundreds of dollars in cash do you think
anybody's gonna turn that in yeah
hopefully somebody need that money and
it's just the way the world works out
busts hope that they didn't use it on
crack cash is gone yeah that's crazy
the restaurants Tuscans you know it's
really weird as I guess a waiter
sometimes you would just like to make if
it's slow to make a couple bucks I would
love to know if she was like stealing
like well drinks or something or is it
just like fountain drinks we're like
they're making like a nickel I mean
cause them a nickel alcohol it might be
like beer keep the cash just imagine if
that's the worst thing you did in your
life you've held on to that for 20 years
and you're a saint I've done worse than
that just this week
that letter so she was saying that that
letter really impact she looks like a
like a librarian at a San Francisco like
very niche interesting bookstore yeah
she looks like she works at a Christian
Lesbian Center right yeah something like
that you know yeah praise the Lord
sometimes yeah Jesus was a lady Jesus
wasn't drag do you guys ever hear your
old vision it's this huge thing that
America is not part of it's like where
they got the idea for American Idol and
I'll one of the guys won it was a labate
Li a drag queen that looked like Jesus
he was a Jesus drag queen what was his
talent just saying it's a singing
competition it's the most I was in a I
was in Australia when I was on I'd never
heard it was it's the most amazing
competition all of Europe can p.m. for
some reason Israel's in it but they all
compete on yeah it's crazy
I love these talent shows that are like
[Music]
dude I did shrooms that k-rock Sweeney
almost acoustic Christmas at the last
one to forum I didn't want to like that
dude I didn't want like 30 seconds for
my they [ __ ] blew it was it the
shrooms oh was it though
it might have been strings but if it got
me dude let me tell you the great
slideshow I've ever seen in my life was
a prophets of rage because they're like
a supergroup of Public Enemy Cypress
Hill and rage against machine what they
all got to get that was a group yeah and
dude he introduced the song he's like
it's be real from Cypress Hills days
like you know these are dangerous times
in these dangerous times we need a
dangerous song and this is the most
dangerous song in them all and it's
killing in the name of dude pulled
mushroom trip place is going nuts my
high school I'm getting goose bumps
now would be like was that your favorite
man that was my favorite band in high
school the year I was gonna sack to the
orchard yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah killing
rage against machine yeah that year that
I was gonna go watch them live because
my parents finally let me they split
right was that 1999 or 2000 or some [ __ ]
like that yeah you know what's crazy
I was so I almost probably got abducted
because I met someone on the internet
and I told him how much I [ __ ] love
rage against machine I was like 13 or 14
at the time and I was like I gotta
[ __ ] go to one of their concerts I
have to do it you know cuz I'm all
political and [ __ ] right and then they
were gonna pick me up and we're gonna go
with a random person on the Internet Wow
I probably did that multiple times but I
remember when I was a kid we were just I
like I grew up in upstate New York which
is shady as [ __ ] and me my friend I was
maybe like I want to say like nine years
old
back then you could just walk around
there's nobody worried by yes but this
woman pulled up in a truck she's like
where's uh do you guys know where the
hospital was and I'm like I'll you just
go down here turn on she's like man I'm
confused man I wish you could just get
in the truck and show me where it is and
I'm like yeah I'll do that my friends
like what are you dumb I don't know who
that is you're gonna get in their truck
and show word that's a yeah yeah he's
like 9 or 10 you are really dumb yes
yeah I was what she almost got molested
twice
it didn't happen I think it's because
I'm a grower not a shower
oh we pulled the pass down no shower
like it was like this weird thing man's
way back the day things were different
were they hot though what do you mean
the guys that were girl you think I
would be complaining if it was a chick
it's not molestation that's hooking up
chick was in the truck I never got into
the truck but there was two other
instances oh oh that's a different story
Oh
nice to molest my teachers my eyes
[Music]